who's going to know your schedule better
than the press secretary who's going to
know your schedule better than the press
secretary your wife okay well your wife
yeah the butler that brings you the
coffee unless if you're a guy named Bill
maybe it's a girl named Monica but for
the most part it's your press secretary
but but I want you to see this clip good
morning the way she says it she's so
proud when she says this
is Gen sake right you gotta see this can
you play this clip uh and that's what
people need to hear from him now it's
important to note President Biden does
nothing at 9am he is a night owl so the
fact that he is doing this at 9am anyway
speaks to how vital the White House
recognizes it is for him to have his
voice out there convene that's the
American public
[Music]
he's so committed you know our president
is so committed because he took a 9am
meeting Tom he took a 9 A.M meeting
American people should be thankful for
the Pres there's only one position you
set us up with that one Pat nine a.m and
by the way the wishes can you play that
she's so proud when she said I think we
need to listen to this one more time
watch this just one more time look look
how proud she is now it's important to
note President Biden does nothing at 9
A.M
Anyway by the way if you're Trump or
DeSantis that's how the ad has got to
start go to exactly President Biden does
nothing at 9am you know what I would
have a list of things that happened at 9
A.M that were bad press play we'll need
to hear from him now it's important to
know okay president okay start from
right there go go to exactly where you
think he says it yeah and try to find a
time it's important to know I think it's
a little bit further back let's go back
right there let's try this there's
nothing at 9am
by the way
I don't know any old man that sleeps in
until 9 A.M though most people old
people are up at the crack of dawn
anyway that's that's actually because
your body's kind of programmed I mean
and I would like to know man Ariana
Huffington I'm telling you I I don't
care I don't know how you brought her up
if she was my wife she wrote a great
book on sleep no no no no she was my
wife I guarantee I get an extra five
minutes of sleep a night I'm telling you
the and Biden 9am come on that was
supposed to be a joke I guess that was a
joke okay there you go uh like you're
here what just happened no no no I am my
question is he's a night owl what time's
he going to bed I don't see Biden up
till 4am just getting it in I think he's
you know or maybe they couldn't find it
wandered off do you really put Biden as
somebody that goes to sleep at 2am
no that's what I'm saying I don't I
don't I don't I don't know what's going
on I will say this if you if you're the
enemy if you're if you're China
if you're Russia by the way if you see
that what are you thinking if your enemy
his press secretary says if the
president does a you know this is an
important meeting because president
doesn't do anything at 9am not a good
luck for Joe Budden by the way not to
get all
um you know somewhere sad here glad is
like we will move the submarines at 8am
no problem this is an article from the
Independent from 2021 that says that the
president begins a short walk home at 7
pm unlike Mr Obama and Mr Trump who sat
up late into the night reading briefing
documents and watching right wing cable
news respectively Mr Biden goes to bed
relatively early
this is so he's not a night owl rob you
just rocked her with what you just said
well and it also says up here that she
uh in the mornings his day starts at 9
00 a.m when he has coffee with his wife
before he sits down and takes calls he
sleeps for 13 hours that's insane no way
I mean dude like he's got to write a
book sleep 50 of your day sleep when
you're dead
but you know what's weird do you
remember what time the first plane hit
the World Trade Center 911 6 30.
Pacific Standard Time 9 30 uh Eastern I
thought it was eight something no
anyway I was at the office so anyway
things happened very early in the
morning okay the first plane hit the
tower at uh 8 46 a.m okay and then the
second time 46 903 yeah okay so yeah so
point is it was right before 9 A.M and
then right at 9am and that's where I was
going with this well that's too much
because it's 40 minutes too early so
he's got to tell the next time somebody
wants to attack listen moving forward
you can't attack us three nine a.m
because that's a guideline that's the
president's guideline I mean dictates
the terms of War okay we cannot go to
war from 9 pm to 9 A.M off limits right
by the way this is this is a joke but
this the funny part it's just not a joke
this is
literally sleeping on the job no here's
what I want to know do you think when
she made that comment her phone blew up
afterwards and you're the freaking press
secretary
former what the hell are you saying
why would you say something like that
that is going to be the perfect ad for
anyone to use against Biden for
2024. she just gave one of the best ads
out there she got a bunch of texts
thanks for the help yeah well what this
this is sort of counter-intuitive
because all we hear is that it's sleepy
Joe so it's maybe
maybe there's some validation that's
going on here and he can maybe actually
sleepy Joe by the way I'm telling you if
there's any stuff that somebody could
say that could finish your campaign this
the statements like this that this could
cause you to not have a chance at nobody
can have a reputation like this in a
Marketplace no one nobody can have a
reputation like this in the marketplace
there's nothing about this that benefits
and strengthens your country going up
against Real bullies in the world by the
way if let's say it's Trump Biden you
know I'm just I'm already in
anticipating because they all have
canned lines I'm already anticipating
Trump being like uh you know you're
sleeping on the job type of thing how do
you know what he's gonna say he's gonna
say you know how he said to bloomerick
he said uh uh uh when he said uh you
know I don't know why apparently
Bloomberg's been asking about a stool to
make him look taller Phoenix and I
needed to I don't know why he's asking
but I'm here he's gonna say something
like look I'm I'm hearing Biden's
talking about the fact that 6 p.m debate
is a little too late because he's got to
go to sleep that's what I'm here in the
marketplace because he got to go to
sleep and he doesn't do anything before
9 A.M so I mean this just gives an
opening for easy shots to be taken but
but then again Biden can be like listen
Trump I could beat you in my sleep buddy
so don't worry about that so he might
have a can line too it's a pretty bad
one though so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you